et des états généraux qui intéresse 52%
de la population française des états
généraux de la femme qui se sont ouverts
ce matin à versailles avec une visite du
premier ministre monsieur chaban delmas
sur place pour nous jean pierre lannes
associé c'est bien normal à une consoeur
madame à ses généraux de la femme on
serait tenté de voir dans cette réunion
quelques réunions de suffragettes ou
quelques réunions de file de la
révolution comme il existe aux états
unis a dit mme beauchamp madame ats la
veille absolument
alors que représentent les états
généraux et bien les états généraux
c'est un congrès qui clôture une grande
enquête nationale réalisée par
l'hebdomadaire elle avec la
participation de france inter et qui
essayait de prendre conscience des
problèmes c'est mine est surtout de
faire prendre conscience aux femmes de
leurs propres problèmes féminins
ces états généraux ont commencé ce matin
et c'était mignon le 22 novembre c'est à
dire dans trois jours
325 femmes échantillonnés par l'insee
c'est à dire choisis en fonction des
socio professionnels sont là et coûte 12
commissions lire les rapports qu'elles
ont réalisées sur l'écran problème finir
quels sont ses principaux pour le
féminin abordé ici tous
célia sap et ils sont abordés en plus
devant les hommes politiques du
gouvernement de l'opposition devant des
scientifiques devant des chercheurs
devant des médecins devant le
psychologue devant des sociologues parmi
les plus importants je citerai le statut
civil de la femme l'amour
le mariage la femme et la santé
l'enseignement l'éducation et le travail
c'est probablement le sujet le plus
important concernant les femmes le
travail vous savez c'est comme ans avec
la formation professionnelle et la
formation professionnelle des filles
commencent dans la famille je ferais
presque dire ouverte en nous se rend
compte à l'heure actuelle qu'un grand
nombre de familles n'envisage pas
l'éducation de l'enfant de la même
manière que celle de leurs questions la
preuve un reportage réalisé auprès de
deux femmes habitant paris l'une madame
rose simic restauratrice trois enfants
l'autre madame fatou puéricultrice son
mari il est électricien
écoutez elle a trouvé un travail qui est
pas mal d'ailleurs puisqu'elle est
caissière qui lui donne du temps mais
est ce que vous trouvez qu une fille
doit faire des études
en principe oui surtout avec la vie
actuelle mais des études poussées
non pas tellement pensé pourquoi parce
que je trouve qu un métier manuel
s'échangent pas mieux pour une fille
faut quoi ça parce que dans la vie
courante pour tous mais une fille ne
peut pas avoir de vie pleine d'intérêt
comme un garçon en suis je ne dis pas si
elle peut être avocate mais ça si on
veut je conseille à ce moment là je
pense que c'est des filles qui ont pas
besoin de se marier mais pour fonder un
foyer représente tout ça avez vous
l'impression madame que lorsque votre
fille se mariera ce sera pour abandonner
son métier et j'espère bien que nous
j'espère qu'elle continuera à nous parce
que ça serait vraiment désolant il reste
à la maison enfin je trouve que c'est
très important de continuer à exercer
son métier disque est important pour
didier avant toute chose se marier
donc si elle a fait quelques études
c'est très bien mais si elle n'a pas été
au delà c'est pas grave
est ce que me réussissent aussi doué
d'un garçon je crois pas enfin oui et
non
c'est pas les moins intelligent je ne
dis pas qu'elle est moins intelligente
mais elle voit pas les choses de la même
façon c'est pas la peine de se sacrifier
trouve pour une fille est partie de moi
je ne dis pas vous avez des filles qui
en valent vraiment le coup
mais en principe non mais je pense que
tout de même on fera l'impossible pour
qu'elle puisse continuer ils furent au
même titre que pour votre fils
exactement
si votre fils votre fils de 20 ans vous
avez demandé d'arrêter les études qu'ils
étaient en train de poursuivre est-ce
que vous l'auriez obligé malgré tout à
poursuivre des études ou bien ce que
vous auriez très bien parce que pour un
garçon c'est important va bien sûr parce
qu'en principe c'est lui le chef de
famille s'il n'a pas un métier dans la
main les mass hysteria faire comment
voulez vous qu'ils suivent y en a une
famille c'est pas possible
oui mais il fit peut malheureusement
devenir veut se marrent oui j'ai ensuite
devenir veut il faut qu'elle un métier
aussi ramené chez lui mais à bon métier
manuel vous assure que pour une femme
c'est valable mais c'est un débat qui
est ouvert un verset en ce moment et que
l'on peut poursuivre au sein de chaque
famille